in the opening scene we are introduced
to an Italian hit man named Leon who
lives in New York City's Little Italy
neighborhood he works for a mafia leader
named Tony because of course that's his
name who operates the Supreme macaroni
company retail store currently Leon is
tasked with a mission to dissuade a
gangster known as fatty fatty from
encroaching on Tony's territory in the
next scene Leon proceeds to track down
fatty at a hotel where he forces a
receptionist into notifying fatty of his
visitor sensing a Potential Threat fatty
alerts his henchmen who then wait for
him outside the elevator as soon as the
elevator door opens they open fire only
to realize they've shot one of their own
following this the henchman's scatter in
search of the Assassin chaos ensues and
Leon being a professional fighter takes
at the henchmen one after another
eventually he traps fatty in a room and
eliminates the remaining henchmen a
terrified fatty dials 9-1-1 for help but
before he can speak to the police Leanna
peers from the Shadows brandishing a
knife at his throat compelling fatty to
shut up desperate fatty offers a
substantial sum of money to spare his
life but Leon dismisses the offer and
instructs him to make a call Tony
answers on the other end threatening him
to leave the city as per his orders Leon
on make sure that fatty understands the
message and then lets him go later on
Leon buys some groceries and returns
back to his building as he climbs
upstairs towards his apartment he sees a
lonely 12 year old girl named Matilda
Landau smoking in the stairwell he
notices a bruise on her face and asks
what happened but the girl lies that she
fell off her bike in reality Matilda
lives with her dysfunctional family in
an apartment down the hall from Leon and
she is frequently beaten up by her
abusive father Matilda's father works
for corrupt DEA agents who pay him to
stash cocaine in his apartment that same
day the agents who discover that someone
has been stealing the cocaine confront
Matilda's father in his apartment one of
the agents named Mulkey pressures him to
confess but Matilda's father insists
that he's innocent seeing this their
drug addict boss Norman turns around and
sniffs him he says that he believes him
but nonetheless assigns him to find out
the culprit by tomorrow at noon Leon
overhears everything from his room but
doesn't intervene the next morning
Matilda's family is going through their
usual daily routine her father over
sleeves her stepmother prepares for work
her half-sister exercises while watching
a fitness program and her four-year-old
brother plays with his toys shortly
after the parents are making out in the
bathroom when their landline ranks
Matilda answers the call and discovers
it's from her school assuming her
mother's identity she's informed by the
school administrator that Matilda has
been skipping class for two weeks the
administrator demands an explanation or
threatens expulsion in response Matilda
claims that she's dead no better way to
skip than by being dead elsewhere Leon
begins his day with his typical routine
exercising and tending to his plant
before leaving his apartment he goes to
a nearby theater to watch his favorite
classical Gene Kelly musicals when he
returns he finds Matilda outside her
apartment again bleeding from her nose
he offers her a handkerchief and in
return she decides to buy him some milk
he looked like he needed it while
Matilda is out shopping Norman and his
armed henchman break into her apartment
Norman grabs a shotgun and ruthlessly
shoots Matilda's family starting with
her stepmother and half-sister before
reaching her father amidst this her
younger brother hides beneath the bed
Norman orders his men to search the
entire house for the stolen cocaine
during a momentary distraction Matilda's
father uses this opportunity to reach
his shotgun and open fire frightened the
little boy attempts to run away but
tragically Falls victim to the
gangster's gunfire as Matilda's father
runs set of ammo he tries to flee but
he's fatally shot by Norman a short
while later Matilda Returns from the
grocery store only to find her father's
lifeless body outside reacting swiftly
she bypasses her own apartment and Rings
Leon's doorbell begging him to let her
in although hesitant at first Leon
eventually opens the door and floods her
in Leon still stays at the door with a
gun in his hand taking a precautionary
motive not long after the gangsters find
the hidden cocaine after which they
leave in the aftermath of these events
Leon offers condolences towards the girl
Matilda claims that she doesn't care
about them and she's only crying for her
innocent brother whom she loved very
much Leon attempts to cheer her up in a
childlike manner thankfully it works as
it brings a smile to her face later Leon
inquires if she has any place to go do
which she responds in the negative
before long Matilda discovers Leon's
profession as a Hitman so she begs him
to take care of her and to teach sure
his skills as she wants to avenge the
murder of her brother in return she
offers herself as a maid and a teacher
as Leon appears to be illiterate however
he brushes her off and tells her to
sleep he doesn't know what illiterate
means anyway the following morning
Matilda brings up the same offer again
but Leon again declines asserting that
being a fighter is not a suitable
occupation for a girl in response
Matilda uses one of his Firearms to
shoot down some pigeons leaving Leon in
shock this act ultimately persuades Leon
and he agrees to train her later that
day the two vacate the apartment and
check into a hotel upon their arrival
the receptionist asks Leon to fill out a
form knowing that he can't read or write
Matilda volunteers to do it on his
behalf starting from the very next day
Leon begins training the girl at first
he teaches her how to use a rifle
emphasizing its advantage in maintaining
distance from the target he then takes
her to a roof and helps her find the
right position for practice he tells her
to hit whoever she wants because the gun
is simply loaded with a paintball
following his guidance Matilda shoots a
jogger and her first attempt turns out
to be good as a part of the training
lyanna signs Matilda physical exercise
such as crunches and encourages her to
drink milk despite her reluctance in
exchange for the training Matilda
carries out errands for lyanna cleans
the room and also helps him learn to
read and write she also makes him drink
milk too because this movie is one big
advertisement for milk amidst this
Matilda notices Leon taking extra care
of his plants as a result she remarks on
his affection for the plants and Leon
responds by explaining that it's like
his best friend because it doesn't pose
questions and lacks Roots much like him
Matilda suggests that if he truly cares
for it he should plant it in a park and
let it Thrive as the days pass by the
two of them begin to enjoy each other's
company and eventually establish an
emotional bond over time Matilda starts
to look up to lyanna and slowly develops
romantic for him she often expresses her
love for him though he doesn't
reciprocate because she's 12 let's pump
the brakes here one day Leon goes to
meet with Tony who has kept all the
money he earned over the years as Leon
was illiterate he didn't want to deal
with it but now he seems to need it Tony
suspects that he now has a woman in his
life so he advises him to be careful he
further assures Leon that his money is
safe with him and tells him to ask for
whatever he needs before departing Tony
assigns him to a new Mission which Leon
agrees to Meanwhile in the hotel Matilda
talks to the receptionist and claims
that Leon isn't her father but her lover
which leaves the man astonished
hopefully not a jealous astonished more
of a call the police astonished the next
day Leon sets out for his mission while
Matilda Returns to her now restricted
apartment however she sneaks inside and
collects some of her stuff she also
retrieves a bulk of cash that her father
had hidden in a secret place just then
she hears someone and entering the
apartment so she quickly hides herself
it turns out to be Norman and two senior
detectives the detectives questioned
Norman about the incident and he feigns
self-defense after a brief discussion
the detectives depart and Matilda
follows Norman in a taxi it doesn't take
long for her to discover that Norman is
a DEA agent later in the day Matilda is
watching cartoons when Leon returns with
blood dripping from his arm before he
can head for a shower the receptionist
knocks on the door and throws them out
of the hotel following this the duo
checks into another hotel where Leon
takes a shower and stitches a wound in
his chest afterwards Matilda offers him
some cash and asks Leon to execute her
brother's Killers however Leon refuses
to take the job and also doesn't allow
her to do it asserting that revenge is
not good he explains that life changes
irreversibly after one commits murder in
an attempt to make her Point Matilda
proposes a game of Russian roulette with
the condition that if she wins she gets
to carry out the ACT Leon says that
she'll lose because he has already heard
the round in the gun despite this the
girl proceeds to pull the trigger but
Leon manages to push the pistol away at
the last moment these two are gonna get
kicked out of a lot of hotels after this
incident Leon takes Matilda to Tony and
requests the mafia leader hire her Tony
is clearly hesitant as she's just a kid
but Leon somehow manages to convince him
to give her a chance following this Leon
takes Matilda on their first mission
they approach the target's room and
Matilda convinces the man to open the
door once the man unlocks the door Leon
breaches the chain and breaks in after a
thorough search Leon instructs the man
to stand still he proceeds to teach
Matilda the proper aim and lets her
shoot the man with paintballs after this
brief training Leon shoots the man
before leaving from that day onward Leon
and Matilda work together and follow the
same approach to eliminate several
targets one after another however her at
one point Leon Hears A Target preparing
a firearm inside so he quickly pulls
Matilda to cover preventing potential
harm he tells her that they should use a
grenade in such a case he then tosses
the grenade inside blowing off the
apartment one day Leon goes to see Tony
and he looks nervous for the first time
he tells Tony to give all of his money
to Matilda if something happens to him
and Tony agrees saying that he can count
on him later Leon gets ready for his
next mission but he decides to go alone
this time because it's a big one while
he is away Matilda remains at home
tending to a plant watching television
and thinking of Revenge after a while of
deliberation as she decides to carry out
her vengeful Mission independently
following this she fills a bag with guns
from Leon's collection and sets out to
kill Norman she Bluffs her way into the
DEA office by posing as a delivery girl
and slowly makes her way to the gents
restroom there she is ambushed by Garmin
who orders her to put the bag down he
questions her about her sender to which
she asserts that she's acting on her own
to avenge her brother's death their
conversation is abruptly interrupted by
one of Norman's henchmen who brings
unsettling news of his friend mulkey's
death it turns out that Leon was the one
who killed him disturbed by this
Revelation Norman orders his man to take
Matilda to his office for the time being
when Leon returns back to his apartment
he finds a note from Matilda mentioning
her intentions concerned for her safety
he rushes to the DEA office and rescues
Matilda killing two more of Norman's men
in the process the same night Matilda
tries to seduce Leon but he rejects her
advances because she's 12. instead he
shares his own story of how he became a
hitman at the age of 18 in Italy Leon
fell in love with a girl from a wealthy
family but his family was poor the two
mid plans to elope but the girl's father
discovered them and killed her out of
anger Leon killed her father in revenge
and fled to New York where he met Tony
and started working for him in the
evening Norman and his men pay a visit
to Tony he expresses his rage as an
Italian Hitman has gone Rogue and is
killing his men he desperately wishes to
meet the Hitman and asks Tony about his
whereabouts Tony who has his family
captured ends up revealing the location
the following morning Matilda is
returning from the grocery store
probably carrying milk when she is
captured by an NYPD ESU team sent by
Norman they take her hostage and ask her
if there's any code to infiltrate Leon's
apartment in response Matilda gives them
the wrong code when the officers use
this incorrect code to knock on the
apartment door Leon becomes alerted the
armed officers enter the apartment but
they find no one inside Leon who is
hiding right above the entrance in a
dope pose closes the door and kills them
upon learning of this Norman summons
extra backup and surrounds the entire
building despite the overwhelming odds
Leon continues to take down the officers
eventually he manages to take an officer
hostage and frees Matilda from their
capture as they slink back into the
apartment Leon creates a Quick Escape
Route for Matilda by Smashing a hole in
an air shaft Matilda initially refuses
to leave without him but he reassures
her that he'll meet her at Tony's Place
in an hour he finally confesses his love
towards her but platonically because
she's 12 before letting her go moments
later the ESU team blows up the
apartment before breaking in in the
chaos that follows Leon disguises
himself as an injured ESU officer and
sneaks out of the apartment he goes
unnoticed by everyone except for Norman
as Leon makes his way out through the
hotel lobby Norman follows him and
shoots him from behind unfortunately
this proves to be fatal with his last
breath Leon press is a grenade pin into
Norman's Palm saying that it is from
Matilda Norman opens Leon's vest only to
find a clown master of grenades which
instantly detonate killing him in the
aftermath Matilda goes to Tony and tries
to convince him to hire her as a killer
however the latter flatly refuses to
hire a 12 year old girl as promised to
Leon Tony hands are 100 boxes in
allowance and sends her back to school
fortunately the headmistress readmits
her after Matilda reveals what happened
in the final scene Matilda walks onto a
field near the school and plants Leon's
beloved houseplant allowing it to grow
freely subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching